well you go to our website and you order
a kit the kit comes in a couple of days
you spit into a tube so that they
collect your saliva you send theirs
packing materials and so forth this is
very much designed to be consumer
friendly you put two back into the
catching packaging material and it's
already pre addressed to go to the lab
where your sample gets handled by the
lab and we it produces a sample of your
genome that's about 500,000 snips little
genetic variations long and then that
gets sent to 23andme and then you're
notified to come to the website and put
in your password and so forth and find
out the data about yourself so then you
can as I mentioned you can look at if
you've gotten your family members to
sign up which is probably the ultimate
and the viral marketing you can compare
yourself to your family members I have
30 family members that I bought kits for
so that's actually a lot of fun you can
again you can look at what are your
genetic tendencies to this or that
condition can you taste the bitter in
broccoli that kind of stuff and it's
it's tremendously educational if you've
studied men dealing genetics and then
you look at your family you can just see
it all working it's it's amazing